شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نستكمل لهذه التغطيه
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان في ابرز
عناوين هذه الساعه الاخباريه
وزير الخارجيه السعودي يستقبلوا مبعوث
البرهان ويؤكد على ضروره وقف كل اشكال
التصعيد العسكري في السودان
وفي نفس كبير في المستشفى
ونقابه الاطباء السودانيه تدعو طرفي
الصراع لوقف الحرب فورا وفتح ممرات امنه
للمستشفيات
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
يحذر من انتشار المواجهات العرقيه مع
استمرار الاشتباكات
وفي هذه الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
الرئيس الاوكرانيه تعهد بشن هجوم مضاد على
روسيا وموسكت تعزز دفاعاتها من ذابولوجيا
وصولا الى القرم
اهلا بكم استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان المبعوث الخاص لرئيس
المجلس السياده الانتقالي السوداني السفير
دفع الله الحاج علي
وقد جرى خلال لقاء بحث الاوضاع الراهنه في
السودان واكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على
دعوه الرياض للتهدئه وتغذيب المصلحه
الوطنيه ووقف كافه اشكال التصعيد العسكري
بما يحافظ على مقدرات ومكتسبات السودان
وشعبه
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ان اجمالي من تم اجلاؤهم من
السودان الى جده وصل الى خمسه الاف وثلاثه
عشر شخصا ينتمون لمئه دوله
واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه انه تم اجلاء 45
مواطنا سعوديا وسته وثلاثين شخصا من
الجنسيه الباكستانيه اليوم من السودان الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بالقطاع
الغربي في جده
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه وفرت
كافه الاحتياجات الاساسيه لرعايه دول
الشقيقه والصديقه تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم
الى اوطانهم
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا ومع دخول المعارك بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثالث تجددت
الاشتباكات حيث شهدت من تقطاء المهندسين
والصالحه مواجهات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله وقصفا بالطيران بحسب مراسل
العربيه وافاد شهود عيان من الحلفايه شمال
مدينه الخرطوم بحري ببدء الجيش في نشر
وحداته والقيام بعمليات تمشيط بعد معارك
عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه
هذا وتجدد سماع دوي في جراث واصوات اطلاق
نار في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
روعه الجيش
تنشيط وضخمه جدا
الان
وهو ضخمه جدا
من الجيش
ومن جانبه اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بمواصله انتهاك الهدنه المعلنه من
خلال عمليه تحشيد تقوم بها غرب العاصمه
الخرطوم
الجيش دان استمرار القصف العشوائي وعمليات
نهب الممتلكات بما فيها البنوك ومنازل
المواطنين
وقال بيان للجيش ان قوات الدعم السريع
حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى سكنه
ومركزي قياده لعملياتها
البيان اكد على استمرار الجيش في تهيئه
الظروف المناسبه لنزول الشرطه تدريجيا الى
الشوارع
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات
بيان الدعم السريع اشار الى ان طائرات
الجيش ما تزال تحلق في سماء الخرطوم
وتنتهي كل الهدنه
الدعم السريع قال ان الجيش يستعد لشن هجوم
في العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه الحلفايه وام
درمان وبحري
هذا وشهدت الخرطوم غارات جويه واطلاق نار
متبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مع
دخول المعارك اسبوعها الثالث
ا ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرف صراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرارا مواجهه بالسلاح وتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفارينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
لمزيد من المتابعه معي من ام درمان الان
الصحفي شهد نادر شهدي اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد الميداني في ام درمان خصوصا وفي
الخرطوم عموما شهدي وابرز مشاهداتك في
الساعات القليله الماضيه
مرحبا اليوم هو ايقاد يكون اليوم في مدينه
ام درمان ازدياد ملحوظ ابو عبد الله حركه
المواطنين هنا في المناطق وتحديدا في
المناطق الطرفيه للمدينه المواصلات بدات
تعمل بشكل متدرج صعوبات ولكن صعوبات واجهه
المواطنين فيها الحصول على
الوقود وقود السيارات
وخلافه المشهد اليوم افضل بكثير عن الايام
الماضيه حركه ملحوظه في مدينه ام درمان
اصطفاف للسيارات امام اصل الوقود املا في
ان تعاود
بشكل طبيعي كما تعلم
الماضيه كانت محطات الوقود طالبيتها كانت
الخدمه ما خلق زحام في بعضها
ولكن اليوم رغم استمرار سلاح الجو تحديث
وطائرات مقاتله من سلاح الجو جهه
ذهابا ولكن المواطنين يتحركون اليوم
باريحيه بشكل بشيء من الاطمئنان النسبي
انا الان في الشارع اتحدث معك حركه تسمع
الضجيجها تفضل
تسمعني
اذا هل يمكن القول شهدي ان هناك احتراما
ولو هشا للهده من قبل الطرفين ام ان
الامور فقط مجرد تصريحات اعلاميه
شهداء الصوت يتقطع فقط لو يعني وفق
متابعتك اخر الاشتباكات والمواجهات اين
وقعت هل من الممكن تحديد ذلك
ومتى هل سمعت السؤال شهدي
الو شهدي انت على الهواء هل تسمعني نعم
نعم كنت سالتك اخر الاشتباكات والمواجهات
متى وقعت واين اذا كان لديك معلومات فقط
لنطلع المشاهدين
نعم بحسب بيان القوات المسلحه الى جنوب ام
درمان كانت تشهد اشتباكاتها
او ايضا سمع الناس هناك اصوات
اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه حتى صباح هذا اليوم
هنا حتى ليله امس كانت هناك اصوات ذوي
مسموعه كبير ولكن اليوم هناك هدوء فقط قلق
بينه والاخرى جهه
ذهابا
طيب بالنسبه الى السلع الاساسيه تحديدا
الخبز المياه الادويه ماذا يمكن ان نقول
شهدي
خصوصا وانك ذكرت انه اليوم افضل من من
غيره هل بدا الناس يصرفون امورهم بشكل
افضل من السابق تحديدا في الوصول الى هذه
السلع
نعم التجاريه هي هي مفتوحه لم تخطبها وان
كانت لي سعادتها معدوده خلال الايام
الاولى من الاشتباكات ولكن كان هناك طلب
عالي على المعادله
السلع الاساسيه في ظل عدم قدره المصانع
التي تصنع المنتجات الغذائيه على
عمليه الانماء الجسور العاصمه كانت بها
اشتباكات حركه الحركه بشكل طبيعي نعم هناك
ربما ستشهد بعض المحال الى كلي ولكن هناك
البعض الاخر
ما يزال يعمل ولكن هناك تخوفات من
ازمه في اسئله الاساسيه في الادويه
وما شابه ولكن نظام استمر الوضع على ما هو
يمكن ان تتدبر هذه الشركات امرها وان تقوم
المحال
مستلزمات المطلوبه من سلع اساسيه من دقيق
وخلافه
منهم درمان الصحفي شهدي نادر شكرا جزيلا
لك شهدي على كل هذه المتابعه
قال رئيس حزب الامه السوداني مبارك الفاضل
ان قوه من قوات الدعم السريع اقتحمت منزله
ونشر حزب الامه السودانيه الذي يتزاعمه
الفاضل مقطع فيديو اظهر منزله وهو حيث
تعرض للنهب والتخري
معي من القاهره مبارك الفاضل المهدي وهو
رئيس حزب الامه سيد مبارك اهلا وسهلا بك
الدعم السريع ان تكون قوته هي من قامت
باقتحام
منزلك بدايه هل لديكم ادله وقرائن تثبت ان
الدعم السريع هو من قام بعمليه الاقتحام
وهم قرض طردوا الحارس
ارد الحارس من البيت
ودخلوا البيت
وكسروا البيت وكما كانوا يبحثوا ايضا عن
وسائق لانهم بعثروا كثير من الوثائق ليس
فقط انهم كسروا الخزن واخذوا ذهب السيدات
وغيره لكن كانوا يبحثوا عن في كان ينظر في
الوثائق
الخاصه بي
فاكره كثير من هذه الوثائق ورموها على
الارض بشكل يعني واضح
وهذه ليس
الحدث الوحيد يعني هم دخلوا منزل السيد
محمد عثمان البرغني في الخرطوم بحري ونهب
وكثير من المنازل يعني هذه قوات فيها عدد
كبير جدا من بوكو حرام من نيجيريا
المالي ومن النيجر وحتى من من موريتانيا
والان عدد كبير منهم الان لجا في
محاولا يهرب وتم
التحفظ عليه في الحدود التشاديه الان اكثر
من الف اجنبي من هذه الدول تم التحفظ
عليهم في الحدود التشاديه
ونحن على صله مع المسؤولين هناك في ادري
في الحدود الشهاديه
الاجانب في هذه القوه ليست لديهم اخلاق
السودان والسودانيين
نعود الى الاساس لماذا استهداف بيوت
مسؤوليه حزب الامه يعني ضمن اي رساله
سياسيه يعني يريد من قام بعمليات الاقتحام
هذه ارسالها لكم يعني ما هي الرسائل التي
تفهمونها من عمليات الاقتحام في حال تاكد
ان قوات الدعم السريع هي من قامت كما
تقولون بعمليه الاقتحام
نعم لانه نحن
وقفنا مع القوات المسلحه السودانيه وانا
هناك في السودان الاسبوع الماضي اصدرت
بيان
تاييد للقوات المسلحه السودانيه ورفض لهذا
الهجوم
العسكري من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وانا
كانت ليست نقاشات مع الفريق مع احمد حمدان
نزلوا
وهو في مرحله عرض عليها التحالف معه
في بدايه هذا العام
وانا نصحته
بعدم
مواجهه القوات المسلحه
واعتذرت عن اي تحالف في مواجهه القوات
المسلحه يعني هو ناقشه معي ان لدي علاقه
معه قبل ان يصبح عسكري
وفي 2012 جاءني في القاهره مع احد اقاربه
من عضويه الحزب وكان مواطن عادي
وجاء عرض علي سبعه الف من قواته لتعمل
معنا في المعارضه
وانا قلت له في ذلك الوقت نحن الان ليس
لسنا بصدد عمل عسكري
ولذلك لن نستطيع
الاستيعاب هذه القوات بعدها صار عميدا في
يعني جمع هذه القوات لصالح البشير
وقابلته ايضا دعاني في منزله في جبره
ونصحته قلت له نصيحتي لك يا اخي
ابتعد عن استفزاز القوات المسلحه طيب
استاذ مبارك استاذ مبارك بس كمان سؤال
يعني يطرح نفسه لماذا لا يعني بتعرف في
الحروب تنتشر عمليات السرقه والنهب ربما
بعض الدهمه استغلوا الظرف هذه الحرب
وقاموا باقتحام منزلك وسرقته ما رايك بهذا
الكلام لانه
حرس والجيران شاهدوهم يعني هناك شهود
بعدين الحرامي لا يستهدف
الامر بهذه الطريقه يعني هم وجدوا الذهب
كسروا الخزن وجدوا الذهب واخذوه
الاموال الموجوده ماذا يعني علاقتهم
بالوسائل يعني هم نزلوا دولاب كامل ملفات
وكذا
وقراوا فيها ورموها على الارض يعني
فواضح بعدين واضح انه يعني هو كان متضجر
جدا يعتبرني حليف للقوات المسلحه
وكان يعني عندما يقول له احدهما انا كنت
مع مبارك ولا كذا يقول ماذا تفعل هناك هذا
حليف البرهان وكذا فيعني فانا السودان
طبعا صغير وهناك كثيرون لهم علاقه به
ومعرفه يعني
فهو متضجر جدا من انه رفضنا التحالف معه
واننا
وقفنا مع القوات المسلحه وحزب الامه حزب
اساسي في غرب السودان ولذلك هو عندما عرض
عليه التحالف قال لي انه انتم يعني لكم
نفوس كبير في في دارفور وانا من دارفور
فبدلا من ان نتواجه
ونتنافس فانا اطلب منكم ان ان نتحالف يعني
ونعمل سويا
فهو فهو يعتبرنا مصدر مصدر يعني خطر عليه
لانه نحن لدينا نفوس كبير في في المنطقه
فهمت هذه النقطه لانتقل معك الى موضوع اي
افق سياسي للحل الان وهل ستكون هنالك اي
هدنه جديده برايك واخر المعلومات التي
تصلكم عن الاتصالات لجمع الطرفين على
طاوله مفاوضات واحده هل من معلومات
شوف الان الوضع
لن يكون هناك في حل سياسي لانه هذا تمرد
عسكري والقوات المسلحه قرارها هي ان تنهي
هذا التمرد عسكريا او يستسلم الذين ما
زالوا في الخرطوم لانه معسكرات الدعم
السريع في كل السودان استسلمت في 16 ولايه
الان واستلمت يعني اسلحتها
قرار القوات المسلحه الان
قبلوا وساطه
ولكن في اطار ان هذه الوساطه ستنظر في
استيعاب ما تبقى من الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه وليس التفاوض السياسي مع
الاستاذ مبارك يعني ترى ان مبادره الايجاد
لها افق ووصلت الى مراحل متقدمه بتعرف كان
في حديث انه لقاءات يعني كل طرف ينتدب
مندوبين عنه ويلتقون في جوبا ذلك هل هذه
المعلومات او هذه المبادره وصلت الى مرحله
متقدمه ام لا حتى الساعه تمت غموض يكتنفها
لا القوات المسلحه اعلن عن
سيمسيله في هذه المباحثات يعني انا لا
اذكر الاسم الان لكن قراته الصبح
كلفوا
عسكري بروده فريق
يتولى
تمثيل القوات المسلحه في هذه المباحثات في
التي ستجري غالبا
فالجيش الان اعتمد فقط مبادره الايجارات
واعتبر انه يعني ليست هناك مجال لاي
مبادره اخرى
بل سيركز على هذه المبادره وبالنسبه
للقوات المسلحه هي مساله البحث كيفيه دمج
بقيه هذه القوات
من القاهره مبارك الفاضل المهدي رئيس حزب
الامه شكرا جزيلا مبارك على هذه المشاركه
وعلى خلفيه المواجهات المسلحه المستمره
بدا موظفون في ولايه الخرطوم عطله الرسميه
بدايه من اليوم وحتى اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب
ظروف الامنيه التي تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل
العطله غرف اداره الازمه والمرافق الخدميه
والحيويه
في سياق متصل اعلنت ولايه القضارف ونهر
النيل في السودان حاله الطوارئ لمواجهه
تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا في
البلاد حيث امر والي القضارف باعلان حال
الطوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف
الاوامر يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن
هذا واعلن والي نهر النيل ايضا حاله
الطوارئ بالولايه ووجه الجهات المختصه
بتنفيذ الامر وفق وسائل اعلام محليه
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى
المواطنين والسكان في المنطقه
المجاوره
مباشره من النيل
من النيل ومن هنا من المرسى وانت ماشي
تتحرك بيه من المناطق السكنيه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره جديده يعني
[موسيقى]
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور فقد اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء حصرها 94 حاله وفاه جراء
الاشتباكات في مدينه الجنينه قبل ذلك اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بيان الله ان لجنه امن
الولايه نجحت بالحد من التوتر القبلي وان
شرطه الاحتياطي تفتح تدريجيا مناطق في
جنوب الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اشار في
بيانه الى ان الموقف العمليتي مستقر في
جميع المناطق العسكريه بالبلاد مؤكدا
استمرار بعض الدول باجلاء راعيها من
الخرطوم وبورتشودا
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو محاولات سرقه بنك
الخرطوم في مدينه ام درمان
[تصفيق]
اكدت الشرطه السودانيه ان القوات
الاحتياطيه المركزي فصيل تابع لها وقد تم
الدفع به الى الشوارع لتامين الاسواق
وممتلكات المواطنين
وشددت على ان من يقودها هم خرجوا كليه
الشرطه والقانون
وقالت الشرطه ردا على الدعم السريع في
البيان انه لا وجود للامن الشعبي في قوات
الاحتياطي المركزي مؤكده بان مقر البنك
المركزي الرئيسي لم يتعرض لاي هجوم وان
الحريق الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد
فروع البنك
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الصحيه اعلنت اقامه
الاطباء في السودان ارتفاع عدد القتل
المدني جراء الاشتباكات الى
425 شخصا واصابه 2091 شخصا
واشارت النقابه الى ان سته عشر مستشفى
تعرض للقصف منذ بدايه المواجهات حيث طالت
عمليات القصف مستشفى البراحه في الخرطوم
بحري يوم امس
من جانبه حذر عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
اطباء السودان في تصريحاته العربيه من ان
انهيار نظام الصحي في البلاد وقال ان هذا
الانهيار اصبح وشيكا بسبب عدم توافر
الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه اللازمه لتقديم العلاج
انهيار النظام الصحي اصبح وشيكا نراه راي
العين
تدهور تام في الخدمات الطبيه في
المستشفيات نقص حاد في المعينات الطبيه
عدم القدره الى الوصول الى المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه او الاسعاف
نقص حاد في اكياس الدم نقص حاد في
معينات غسيل الكلى نقص حاد في الادويه
المنقذه للحياه والادويه المستخدمه في
العمليات الجراحيه النقص في كل مكان
يكاد نكون وصلنا الى المرحله الصفريه في
عدد من المعينات الطبيه الضروريه
نحاول
عبد الله قال ايضا العربيه ان هناك مخاوف
حقيقيه من ان تصل البلاد الى وقت لا
تستطيع فيه الكوادر الطبيه من تاديه
واجباتها بسبب هذا الاقتتال نحن نتخوف من
تاتي لحظه لا يستطيع الكادر الطبي القيام
بواجبه المهني والاخلاقي نريد كاولويه
الان هي وقف هذه الحرب فورا ومن ثم فتح
ممرات امنه للوصول الى المستشفيات وايضا
فتح كل المخازن الطبيه داخل وخارج الخرطوم
الى وتغذيه المستشفيات فتح المجال الجوي
والبري والبحري للمعينات الانسانيه من
الدول الصديقه والمحبه للشعب السوداني
ايضا نحن نطالب بعدم استهداف الكوادر
الطبيه وعدم استهداف المنشات الطبيه
من جانبها قالت رئيسه العمليات المدنيه
لليونيسف في السودان في بيان لها قالت ان
اليونيسف على درايه بان هناك اكثر من 15
مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
مؤكده ان الوضع الحالي الذي يشهده السودان
من قصف وهجمات هو في تزايد
على درايه تامه بان قبل حدوث ازمه السودان
الحاليه هناك اكثر من 15 مليون شخص بحاجه
الى المساعدات الانسانيه من بينهم ثمانيه
ملايين طفل وان القصف الجوي والهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه للمياه وتدمير اللقاحات
الحيويه التي تشهدها البلاد ستكون في
ارتفاع ملحوظ
وافادت رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه لليونيسف
ايضا بان الوضع في السودان لا يساعد
العاملين في المجال الانساني لايصال
الخدمات الى المحتاجين مؤكده اما بعض
العاملين تعرضوا للهجوم
القصف والصراع وانعدام الامن في البلاد لا
تساعد العاملين في المجال الانساني بايصال
الخدمات الى المحتاجين لقد تعرض بعض
العاملين في المجال الانساني للهجوم
بالاضافه الى من لقي حتفه في الطريق الوضع
في غايه الصعوبه
[موسيقى]
وضع انساني من سيء لاسوء يعاني منه
السودان
فقبل النزاع الحالي حتى 15 مليون شخص
كانوا بحاجه لمساعده انسانيه منهم ثمانيه
ملايين طفل
610 الاف طفل كانت تتم معالجتهم من سوء
التغذيه ومع اشتعال الحرب تتوقع اليونيسف
تدهور الوضع الانساني وتعجز عن حصر
الاعداد
فوسط شحي الامدادات الاساسيه واستهداف
المشافي ترجح المنظمه ازدياد اعداد
الوفيات بين الاطفال
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا تنضم الي من
الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن وهي
عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان دكتوره هويدا اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه التغطيه نريد منك بدايه اطلاله اليوم
على المشهد الاستشفائي في السودان عموما
وفي الخرطوم خصوصا مع دخول هذه المواجهات
اسبوع الثالث
السلام
للمصابين وشكرا لقناتكم لتغطيتها المستمره
وحقيقه انا اتحدث عن منطقه شرق النيل
ومستشفى البان جديد اللي هو المستشفى
الوحيد الموجود في منطقه شرق النيل لا زال
يعمل ونحن نعمل في ظروف صحيه صعبه للغايه
لازمنا نستقبل اعداد كبيره من المصابين
وعدات كبيره من مرضى الاخرين وحقيقه لا
نستطيع تقديم الخدمه كما يجب يعني احنا
بنقدم
الازعافات الاوليه فقط يعني نحن داخل غرفه
العمليات حتى لا نستطيع
ان نعمل برابر او ستاندر يعني احنا حتى
التعقيم لا يتم بالطريقه كما يجب ان يقوم
بها التعقيم لكثره العمليات ولكثره
الاصابات
وحليمه الخدمات الاوليه لا نعرف الى اين
نوجههم يعني اكثر المصابين احنا يتم نقلهم
الى ولايه اخرى يعني الان احنا عاده
نحول المصابين الى ولايه الجزيره مدينه
مدنيه
وحقيقه لا ندري يعني المخاطر التي تقابلهم
بالطريق يعني هناك مخاطر كثيره ربما في
طريقهم الى مدني ربما يعني يتعرضوا
للمخاطر الوضع يزداد سوءا والكوادر الطبيه
لا
وهي المستشفى الوحيد الذي يقدم خدمه
الجراحه والنساء والتوليد والعظام
الكوادر الصحيه اصبحت مرهقه للغايه حقيقه
وعندي عدد من الاطباء الان هو اصبح مريضا
يعني وهو يعمل وهو يعني يرتاح
نعطيهم السوائل الوريديه ويعودوا للعمل
مره اخرى
دكتور هويدا بالنسبه الى موضوع المياه
والكهرباء يعني
متوافره في في المشافي التي ما زالت تعمل
هذا واحد كمان في كلام يعني افاء اثرت
اكثر من منظمه دوليه المخاوف من تفشي او
مثل الملاريا والكوليرا هل بداتم تلحظوا
اي حالات من ذلك ام لا هذه مبالغات لا
اساس لها من الصحه
لا حتى الان لكن نتوقعها بكثره على فكره
وتوقعي التهابات للجروح لمصابيع العمليات
وعمليات القيصريه نحن الان نقوم بعدد من
العمليات القيصريه للنساء الحوامل اتوقع
تنتهي بهذه العمليات والجروح لاننا نعمل
في ظروف صعبه
اخاف جدا من
ان تنتهي بهذه الجروح
اتمنى اتمنى من وزاره الصحه ان
تقوم جماعه
يهود والكهرباء على الازليه يعني نحن في
استلمنا جزء بسيط من وزاره الصحه من
المعينات وهنا
ك من المنظمات
دعمتنا يعني ولكن تعرض وطول هذا الامداد
الينا صعبه يعني نحن متصل بهم ويقولون لنا
يعني هذه المعينات متوفره لكن كيف تصل
الينا في منطقه شرق النيل يعني نحن من
الخوف من ان كيف تصل الينا هذه المعينات
الصحيه
نعاني طب بالنسبه الى الكوادر الطبيه قلتم
انكم تعانون هل يوجد لديكم مثلا اي خطه
الطوارئ يعني
تقوم بشكل او باخر كفيله بسد هذا نقص ام
لا يعني هذا النقص لا يمكن سده دكتوره
هويدا
في صفحاتنا
والرجال الاحيائي على فكره يعني يساعدوننا
كثيرا الرجال الاحياء بالقرب من المستشفى
لنبحث عن اطباء وممرضين وسترات الذين
يسكنون قريبا من المستشفى حتى يعني لا
يتعرضوا للضرب والقذف في يوميا يعلم يصل
الينا عدد من الممرضين لكن حقيقه يعني حتى
في غرفه العمليات لا يوجد لدينا اخصائي
تخدير يعني احنا حتى العمليات ونحن بناخذ
عالي جدا على فكره يعني بنستغل العمليه
بمساعده فني تخدير والنواب يعني حتى الان
ليس لدينا اخصائي تقدير بغرفه العمليات
منذ 15 يوم
طيب بالنسبه الى المنظمات الدوليه التي
كانت عاده يعني تعمل في اكثر من منطقه
ومدينه في السودان وتقدم
خدمات
تحديدا خدمات طبيه وادويه هل لديكم اي
داله الان اتصالات معها وهل وعدتكم
بالمساعده
نعم نعم هنالك اتصال دائما عدد من
المنظمات وفي عدد من المنظمات الان وفرت
الينا انداد ونحن على فكره لصعوبه الموقف
اخذنا هذا الخطر على انفسنا والان ارسلنا
عدد من الشباب
لقطع الكبري المنشيه والذهاب الى الخرطوم
لاستلام هذه المعينات لكن حقيقه نحن الان
نعيش في قلق تام لا ندري هل سيصلون ام لا
من الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن عضو
منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعزائي المشاهدين تفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه
انعكس على قطاع الادويه حيث ازدادت ازمه
نقص الادويه في الخرطوم مع استمرار
المواجهات المسلحه
وحذر تجمع الصياد الى المهنيين بالسودان
من كارثه صحيه بسبب عمليات نهب الصيدليات
وشركات ومخازن الادويه في مدن العاصمه
الثلاث بالتزامن مع اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات في ام درمان حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك هي ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في
الحاء الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في
الظروف العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت
اكبر بالاضافه للفوط الصحيه
للسيدات تكاد تكون الان ما موجوده خالص
كمان مشكله الالبان عند الاطفال دي مشكله
كارثه حقيقيه الان الالبان غير موجوده
وجدت الاحداث الدواء حقي
انسانين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او اذا تفتشوا ما خلوا
اي حته فتش عشان تقول ايه ويسعد ما خلينا
صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حته
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
الخلصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط
[موسيقى]
وجدت الاحداث الدوحه
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها
[موسيقى]
حذر المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف حذر من انتشار
المواجهات الاثنيه والقوميه في البلاد في
ظل احتدام الاقتتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع واضاف يوسف ان استمرار الحرب التي
لن ينتصر فيها اي طرف ستفتح بابا
للمواجهات القوميه في كل البلاد ولم تصبح
هناك دوله بالاساس
قبل ذلك قال شهاب الطيب المتحدث الرسمي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير للعربيه ان القوى
السياسيه تتواصل مع اطراف دوليه واطراف
عسكريه في الداخل للتفاوض والوصول الى حل
للازمه
لانه نحن على تواصل برضه مع مع اطراف
دوليه ومع بعض الاطراف من العسكريين في
الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تفاوض لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدوا
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الان ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء اكد الجيش
مواصله اجلال رعايه دول اجنبيه من قاعده
وادي سن الجويه دون تهديدها مع استمرار
المواجهات المسلحه مع قوات الدعم السريع
وكانت كل من مصر والولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا قد اعلنت ايقاف عمليات اجلاء
المواطنين من مطار قاعده وادي سيدنا
لاسباب امنيه وحثت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
في بيان لها الموجودين في القاعده على
مغادرتها في اقرب فرصه متاحه كما حذرت
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم مواطنيها من
التوجه لمطار وادي سيد نبي بسبب تصاعد
التهديد الامني والعنف في المطار ومحيطه
وحول جهود السعوديه في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان يستمر الجسر الجوي في تنفيذ خطته
في اجلاء الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه نحو
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في مدينه جده
هذا وقد وصلت اليوم الى القاعده طائره
عسكريه تابعه للقوات الجويه السعوديه حيث
افاد مراسل العربيه بان طائره سعوديه اجلت
82 شخصا بينهم خمسه واربعون سعوديا من
بورتسودان الى ميناء جدا
هذا واكد الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
على ضروره عدم التدخل الخارجي في الازمه
السودانيه كما اكد في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
رئيس الوزراء الياباني
على ضروره الوقف الفوري والدائم لاطلاق
النار في السودان
في هذه الاثناء اظهرت صور الاقمار
الصناعيه اصطاف عشرات الحافلات على معبر
ارجين الحدودي تحمل الفارين من النزاع
الدائر في السودان
وقد اظهرت الصور ازدحاما على المعبر في
انتظار عبور الحافلات الى الجانب المصري
[موسيقى]
هكذا تبدو بوابه الخروج من معبر ارجين
تقلص كبير في اعداد القادمين من السودان
وتقلص ايضا في اعداد الحافلات التي
تنتظرهم منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
حولهم بقى على المعبر الثاني اللي هو
النهري ده بس وحولوا الاتوبيسات وحولوا
الناس كلها على هناك النهارده الحركه
خفيفه قد تكون الحركه من قصه طبعا الجانب
الاشتباكات بس احنا ما نعرفش اي حاجه ايه
اللي حاصل في الجانب السوداني
[موسيقى]
اصحابه سيارات نقل البضائع الكبيره
سينجحون اخيرا في المرور من معبر ارجين
والدخول الى الاراضي السودانيه بعد توقف
دام اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
نحن الان داخل احد الحافلات التي خرجت
اخيرا من معبر ارجين من يستقلون هذه
الحافله يشعرون بالارهاق وتحدثوا معنا على
معانوه من خلال هذه الرحله الطويله لكل
الناس تتجه لحلفه فاحنا كنا اخر بس جاي
على الارجيله
زحمه شديده في غريب 30 باص والمعبر زحمه
شديد لكن احنا شنو
خشينا بس عملنا الاجراءات ولقينا خلينا
على بعض مصريه جابتنا جابتنا
[موسيقى]
وسواء كان القادمون ياتون من خلال البري
او مينائي ابو سمبل النيلي فان الرحله
تكتمل اخيرا بالوصول الى الحدود المصريه
احمد عثمان لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
ميناء ابو سمبل النيلي
[موسيقى]
ومن معبر ارجين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه بقناة احمد عثمان احمد اهلا
وسهلا بك يعطيك الف عافيه كيف بدلك مشهد
النزوح والاجلاء اليوم وابرز مشاهداتك في
هذه الاوقات احمد
من منذ الامس بدا من الواضحا بان معبر
ارجين يشهد هدوءا كبيرا عدد الذين يخرجون
منه قليل اذا ما قلنا بالايام السابقه نفس
الشيء ينطبق اليوم السبب في هذا بانه قد
تم اتخذ قرار ربما بان يكون هناك تخفيف من
الضغط على هذا المعبر الذي شهد تكدسا
كبيرا ولا يزال يشهد تكدسا من الجانب
السوداني حتى الان كما تظهر بعض الصور
ولكن القرار الذي اتخذ بتوجيه الكثير من
القادمين او النازحين من الحدود السودانيه
الى المنفذ البري الاخر وهو منفذ قصته هذا
المنفذ الذي يعني يبعد عن مدينه ابو سمبل
حوالي اكثر من 100 كم 60 كم منها يتم مرور
العبور منها من خلال الحافلات ثم التوجه
من خلال
العبارات الليبيه كما راينا في التقرير
الى مدينه ابو سمبل التي تبعد عن الحدود
او الخط الثاني والعشرين الذي يفصل ما بين
مصر والسودان بحوالي 150 كم لتستانف
الرحله مره اخرى الى مدينه اسوان خطوط
وطرق الاجلاء سواء من الخرطوم او غيرها من
المدن باتجاه الحدود المصريه يمكن القول
ان معظمها امن ام لا لا يكمل قول ذلك احمد
وفقا لشهود العيان الذين يخرجون ويتحدثون
اليك
نعم يعني ربما هذا السؤال يعني يعني هناك
اعتمادات على اجابات كثير من شهودنا يعني
اذا تحدثنا عن الايام الاولى للخروج فاغلب
شهود العيان اتاكدوا بان عمليه الخروج من
الخرطوم كانت صعبه للغايه وان اغلب
الاشتباكات التي كانت تدور في الخصوم وام
درمان وفي محيطها للوصول الى الطرق الاخرى
كانت اغلب الاشتباكات او اغلب ملامح الخطر
كانت في هذه المرحله اما بعد ذلك في
التوجه الى
الحدود كانت امنه بعض الشيء باستثناء بعض
المضايقات او قطع للطريق او الى غيره هذا
ما يؤكده البعض ولكن في الايام الاخيره
تاكد من خلال الحوارات مع البعض الذين
عبروا بان هناك تغيرا قد حصل في مضايقات
التي يتعرض لها القادمين عبر بعض الطرق
المعتاده وهذه كانت من ضمن الاسباب التي
دفعت البعض الى التوجه الى الطريق الاخر
او المنفذ الاخر منفذ وهو عن طريق اخذ
طريق وادي حلفا اقرب المدن السودانيه على
الحدود مع مصر من ناحيه قسطل يعني يقال ان
هذا الطريق اكثر تاميرا من الطريق الذي
كان ياخذه الكثير من السودانيون للتوجه
الى منفذ اركين البري خلال الايام الاولى
من عمليات طيب احمد توقعات الجانب المصري
بان الايام المقبله ستشهد مزيدا وموجه
كبيره من النزوح والاجلاء ام لا يعني
التوقعات مش بهذا يعني الحجم لانه كما
يقول البعض يعني من خرج فقط خرج ومن قرر
البقاء يعني قرر البقاء
يعني لا احد يستطيع ان يقول ان يكون هناك
حسم لهذه النقطه لان عمليات النزوح
والخروج كما ذكرت هي معتمده ربما على
ارهاصات ما يدور في الداخل هناك من يقول
بالفعل كما ذكرت انت طالب بان من خرجك خرج
وهناك من يقول بان يعني فتره الهدوء الذي
برغم ان الهدى المتقطعه ورغم ان يعني هناك
لا يوجد اي التزام كبير ولكن ربما ذروه
العنف قد يعني انتهت الى حد ما وبالتالي
ان الايام المقبله قد تشهد المزيد من
تثبيت لهذه الهدد وبالتالي فان الارقام
التي وصلت اوقات تصل بالفعل الى الحدود
سوف تتوقف او تقل او انه لا قدر الله كما
يتخيل البعض بانه فشل هذه الهدى وعوده مره
اخرى الى ذروه المواجهات خلال كما راينا
خلال الايام الاولى قد تشهد موجيات نزوح
جديده الى الحدود المصريه لا احد يستطيع
ان يتجاهل فالكل يترقب المشهد الداخلي في
السودان الذي على اساسه فيتم تقييم للموقف
على الحدود
من معبر الارجينا على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل عربي احمد عثمان شكرا
جزيلا لك احمد على كل هذه المتابعه
اما في ميناء بورسودان فقد وصلت اليوم اول
شاحنه مساعدات انسانيه من الصليب الاحمر
جو ضمن عمليه الطوارئ التي ينفذها منذ
دلاع المعارك في السودان
وافاد بيان للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
بان الشحنه التي ارسلت من عمان تزنوا
ثمانيه اطنان وتضمنت معدات جراحيه لدعم
المستشفيات
ومتطوعين من جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السودانيه الذين يقدمون الرعايه الطبيه
للجرحى الذين اصيبوا خلال عمليات القتال
تفاقم الاوضاع الصحيه ان عكس على قطاع
الدواء وسط مخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير
الدواء في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع
استمرار هذه الشباكات
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغ هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك خيار
ادويه الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي او
الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
الدين طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شحو الان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض مقلق وجد
الاحداث الدوحه من سنين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتشوا ما خلا
اي حته فتج عشان القليب
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حته ما
لقينا وحتى عربيه عشان يجيبوا لي الدواء
ما في بنزين ما في هناك طريقه نمرق من
البلد عشان نمشي نفتش الدواء نجيبه اما
بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا يزال القليل منها
الذي يعمل في الخرطوم يعاني نقصا حادا في
الادويه والمستلزمات العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه
المتعلقه بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما
يفاقم من معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف
الامداد الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني
العربيه
هذا وشهد حي جبره جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم
اصواتها الشبكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع نتابع
[موسيقى]
اذا نواصل هذه
التغطيه للاشياء السودانيه من قناه
العربيه
ونتابع ايضا في جديد الاخبار بين عزم
الجيش عن حسم المعركه واصرار قوات الدعم
السريعه على الصمود الحرب قد لا تنتهي في
المستقبل المنظور وفقا لمراقبين
الصراع في السودان يتواصل لينذر بتحول
البلاد لبؤره توتر اقليمي وجبهه قتال قد
تمتد لدول الجوار توتر صاحبته دعوه دوليه
واقليميه الى ضروره نزع فتيل الازمه
والالتزام بمسار الهدنه واعاده البلاد
لاكمال المسار الديمقراطي المتعثر منذ
سنوات طويله الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان هذا ما اكده امينه العام انطونيو
غوتيريش الذي دعا الجيش وقوات الدعم
لتغليب لغه الحوار وانهاء الصراع الذي يجب
ان يكون مرتبطا بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
السودان الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان وستفعل كل ما بوسعها لتوفير
الظروف الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم
الانساني للشعب السوداني ومن نيويورك ايضا
اكدت مندوبه بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان
تهدف للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات
الاتحاد الافريقي فيما يخص الوضع الحالي
في السودان الذي تحول لبقعه جغرافيه ساخنه
ما نود فعله هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل
من مجلس الامن لمقترحات ايجاد للتقدم نحو
وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم العوده للعمليه
السياسيه
التطورات الحاصله دفعت باطراف دوليه
واقليميه وعربيه لطرح مبادرات تهدئه بين
الطرفين والتوسط لاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار لتعبيد الطريق امام حكومه مدنيه حيث
ان المبعوث الاممي للسودان اشار الى ان
طرفي الصراع في السودان منفتحان على
الحوار الخراب الدمار وفق مراقبين فان
انقاذ البلاد من الفوضى والدمار وتشكيل
حكومه تكنوقراط تضمن الخروج من الازمه
الحاليه يتطلب تجديد الرياده الدبلوماسيه
من طرف المجموعه الدوليه ومعاقبه الاطراف
التي تسببت في زعزعه استقرار السودان
[موسيقى]
الان الى طائفه من الاخبار الدوليه في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه فقد اكد الرئيس
الاوكرانيس كان قواته جاهزه لشن هجوم مضاد
رغم عدم استلام الطائرات المقاتله من
الغرب
بصراحه كانت الطائرات ستساعدنا كثيرا في
الهجوم المضاد لكننا نتفهم ايضا انه لا
يمكن ادراجها ضمن خططنا في الوقت الحالي
وهذا هو السبب في اننا سنبدا الامر قبل
استلام طائره اف 16 او انواع اخرى روسيا
مطمئنه لاعتقادها اننا ما زلنا بحاجه الى
شهرين لبدء الهجوم المضاد بعد التدريب على
الطائرات نقول هذا لا يحدث سنبدا الهجوم
ونمضي قدما لكن في الوقت نفسه هذا مهم
للغايه لاستلام الطائرات المقاتله الغربيه
في هذه اثناء كشفت شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه عن معلومات وفقا لصور التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه ان روسيا انشات خنادقه
دفاعيه تمتد من القرم حتى دونتس وذلك
تحسبا للهجوم الاوكراني المضاده مشيره الى
ان روسيا عملت طيله الاشهر السته الماضيه
على بناء مجموعه معقده من الدفاعات التي
يصعب اختراقها حيث تتركز الخنادق الروسيه
بشكل اكبر قرب الخطوط الاماميه في الشرق
وتمتد من زابولوجيا الى شبه جزيره القرم
وفي اخر تطورات الاوضاع في مدينه باق موت
حيث تدور المعارك منذ اشهر قال المتحدث
باسم القوات الاوكرانيه
ان بلادهما تزال تسيطر على طريق امداد هام
يؤدي الى المدينه مؤكدا لوسائل اعلام
محليه ان الوضع في بخمت ما يزال صعبا بسبب
محاولات القوات الروسيه السيطره على هذه
الطريق المؤدي للمدينه الا ان قوات بلاده
لن تسمح للروس بقطع الخدمات اللوجستيه عن
الجيش الاوكراني
هذا ونشرت وزاره دفاع روسيه صورا لمقاله
انه استهداف لوحدات عسكريه جنوب اوكرانيا
وقالت الدفاع الروسيه انه تم تنسيق القصف
عبر صور مباشره تم التقاطها بطائره بدون
طيار
[موسيقى]
تعتزم كوريا الشماليه تعزيز الردع العسكري
ضد كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
منتقده اتفاق القمه الذي عقد هذا الاسبوع
بين البلدين بشان تعزيز ردع الموسع
الامريكي
ووصفته بانه نتاج سياسه عدائيه شائنه ضد
وكانت واشنطن قد وافقت على نشر غواصات
مسلحه نوويه في كوريا الجنوبيه مع اشراك
في التخطيط النووي لمواجهه التهديدات
النوويه من جارتها الشماليه
هذا وانتقدت وسائل اعلام حكوميه في كوريا
الشماليه زياره الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي
ينسوك الى الولايات المتحده حيث قالت
مذيعه اخبار في تلفزيون كوريا الشماليه ان
افعال يونسوكيول تحول كوريا الجنوبيه الى
ترسانه امريكيه وقاعده متقدمه للحرب
النوويه وتضر بامن ومصالح البلاد
ان افعال الخائن يونسو رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه الخانعه للولايات المتحده تحول
كوريا الجنوبيه الى ترسانه امريكيه وقاعده
متقدمه للحرب النوويه وتضر بامن ومصالح
ليس فقط شبه جزيره الكوريه ولكن ايضا
المنطقه لا يمكن ابدا التسامح مع التحركات
الحرب النوويه الخطيره التي قامت بها
الولايات المتحده والمجموعه العميله في
خلق وانكار وجود جمهوريه كوريا الشعبيه
الديمقراطيه وسيتعين عليهم دفع ثمن
افعالهم المتهوره
افادت وكاله بلومبرج بان الدول الاوروبيه
باتت تضع قيودا جديده على الصادرات
والاستثمارات الصينيه بسبب استيائها من
علاقات بكين الوثيقه مع الرئيس بوتين
مشيره الى ان دول مثل المانيا وايطاليا
تدرساني وضع الضوابط التي اعتمدتها
الولايات المتحده على التصدير والاستثمار
لاستهداف الصين
ووفقا للوكاله فان واشنطن والاتحاد
الاوروبي يعملان على تطوير ادوات جديده
لابطاء تقدم الصين في عده مجالات تشمل
اشباه الموصلات والدفاع مضيفه انهما
يناقشان وضع ضوابط على التصدير مع التشديد
الرقابه على الاستثمارات وزياده التعاون
في مجال المواد الحيويه
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو انه
واثق من امكانيه التوصل الى اتفاق بشان
خطه الاصلاح القضائي المثيره للجدل التي
طرحتها حكومته مؤكدا على ان ادارته تعمل
على حل هذا الجدل من خلال المفاوضات
هناك نقاش اساسي بيننا بشان الاصلاح
القضائي لكننا نبذل جهدا لحل هذا الجدل من
خلال المفاوضات اعتقد انه بفضل النوايا
الحسنه للطرفين فانني على ثقه من امكانيه
التوصل الى الاتفاق وانا اؤيد ذلك تماما
اقيل وزير الصناعه الايراني ليكون اول عضو
في حكومه الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي تتم اقالته
جاء ذلك بعد ان صوت البرلمان الايراني على
القرار اذ اتهم البرلمانيون الوزير رضا
فاطمي بالفشل في السيطره على ارتفاع
الاسعار وسوء الاداره
في اداره النازحين بمحافظه مارب من بطء
الاستعدادات لمواجهه الفيضانات المتوقعه
ان تضرب البلاد خلال موسم الامطار القادم
وابلغ خالد الشجري مدير وحده النازحين في
مارب بان حاله تاهب والاستعداد لمواجهه
الفيضانات المتوقع حدوثها في المحافظه
خلال موسم الامطار بطيئه مقارنه بحجم
الكارثه المتوقع حدوثها بفعل هذه السيول
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره
يصحبكم في الساعه المقبله من الرياض
الزميلي في الاحمر التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات